[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und marietas lomka guten Abend
105 stimmen da sage noch mal jemand auf
meine Stimme kommt es nicht an doch es
gibt immer wieder selbst bei
Bundestagswahlen Ergebnisse die so knapp
sind dass es tatsächlich ein Unterschied
macht ob man zur Wahlurne gegangen ist
oder nicht sollte Franziska giffeier
Regierende Bürgermeisterin Berlins
bleiben dann wegen dieser 105
Wählerinnen und Wähler die in diesen
Vorsprung vor der Grünen Konkurrentin
verschafften ob es aber so kommt ist der
noch lange nicht gesagt denn der
eigentliche Wahl Sieger die CDU wird
alles versuchen um aus diesem Erfolg
auch eine Regierungskoalition zu
schmieden
das wird allerdings schwer berichtet
Frank Buchwald
Sieger lächeln wenn auch noch etwas
schüchtern Kai Wegner hat seiner CDU in
Berlin das beste Wahlergebnis seit mehr
als 20 Jahren erkämpft und ein
Regierungsauftrag sagt Wegner es ist ein
ganz klares Votum der Berlinerinnen und
Berliner alle drei Regierungsparteien
haben verloren die CDU hat über 10%
zugelegt Blumen deshalb von Parteichef
wegen das Erfolg für Friedrich Merz der
Beweis die CDU kann auch Großstadt
das
28,2 Prozent der Wählerinnen und Wähler
in dieser Stadt der CDU ist zutrauen die
Probleme dieser Stadt zu lösen ist ein
gutes Zeichen ermutigt uns auch auf
diesem Weg weiterzugehen Blumen auch für
Franziska Giffey für die SPD aber war
das gestern ein bitterer Abend die
Wählerinnen und Wähler wünschen sich
Verbesserungen und Veränderungen es muss
vieles angepackt werden das ist sehr
deutlich geworden auch schon in den
vergangenen Wochen nur gut 100 Stimmen
mehr als die Grünen harter Schlag für
die Regierende Bürgermeisterin gefeiert
aber kämpft um ihr Amt
dieses Ergebnis ja auch in Demut an aber
wir
sind diejenigen die als Sozialdemokraten
und als diejenigen die zweitstärkste
Kraft geworden sind auch den Anspruch
erheben diese Stadt weiter
mitzugestalten die Grünen fühlen sich
bestätigt stabiles Ergebnis in Berlin
Ansporn auch in der Ampel die Klimaziele
einhalten das ist unsere Aufgabe vor der
wir als gesamte Bundesregierung stehen
und dann nehmen wir natürlich auch die
Koalitionspartner die Verantwortung
wunschkoalition für Berlin bleibt in
dessen Rot-Grün-Rot auch wenn
Spitzenkandidatin jarasch mit der CDU
wenigstens sondieren möchte auch die
Linke würde trotz Verlusten am liebsten
weitermachen in der Koalition mit SPD
und Grünen die AFD gewinnt hinzu mit ihr
aber will keiner koalieren
die FDP scheitert ein weiteres Mal an
der 5%-Hürde Berlin verlängert eine
Serie verlorener Landtagswahlen
die FDP hat fraglos nicht von der
Wechselstimmung profitieren können das
ist klar aber trotzdem sind politische
Schlussfolgerungen nötig auch für die
Politik der Ampel in Berlin aus dem
Wahlergebnis
dass wir hier gemeinsam in der
Hauptstadt als Ampelkoalition hatten
keine Politik gegen das Auto deshalb
keine irreguläre Migration klingt wie
eine Kampfansage Ton und Themen der FDP
in der Ampelkoalition dürften künftig
wohl sehr viel entschlossener klingen
das alles wollen wir noch ein wenig
näher analysieren der Parteienforscher
und Politikwissenschaftler Karl Rudolf
Korte ist bei uns im Studio genannte
Professor guten Abend bleiben wir gleich
mal bei dem Unglück der FDP die fünfte
Landtagswahl in Folge ziemlich in den
Sand gesetzt wie viel Unruhe kann das in
die Ampelkoalition bringen also Herr
Kubicki spricht ja schon von einem Ende
des peacements ja Unruhe nach Serien
wird sich nicht noch dramatisch steigern
davon ist eigentlich nicht auszugehen
aber er wird konstant diesen Unruhe Herd
auch am Kochen halten denn gegenüber den
WLAN sieht man ja keine Veränderung das
ist auch das warum die Wähler hier
diesmal der FDP nicht gefolgt sind die
zeitenwände hat ja dazu eigentlich
geführt dass man sich pragmatisch
anpasst und sich verändert und Wähler
honorieren in der Regel das pragmatische
nicht das ideologische
dann schauen wir noch mal auf die
Berliner Ebene also rein rechnerisch
würde das ja für Rot-Grün-Rot reichen
aber man spürt doch oder man glaubt
jedenfalls zu spüren so ein gewisses
Unwohlsein doch auch bei der SPD mit
Frau giffer den sich nun wirklich nicht
als Wahl Gewinnerin fühlen kann aber
auch die Grünen man bleibt zusammen dann
mit den Linken und Landespolitik ist
nicht Bundespolitik aber der Ukraine
Krieg hat ja doch auch fundamentale
Gräben aufgerissen ja zumal ein
Demokratie Verstoß ja der Anlass war
hier noch mal neu zu wählen die
Wiederwahl sollte hier die Demokratie
heilen also den Vertrauensvorschuss
halten wenn jetzt die Bürger den
Eindruck haben das aus ihrem Votum
eigentlich nicht wirklich etwas wird
oder die Übersetzungsleistung nicht
funktioniert dann kann man auch keinen
Vertrauen wirklich in seine Wahl
stabilisieren denn diejenigen die sich
einen Wechsel gewünscht haben sind jetzt
nicht befriedet und die ein weiter so
wählen wollten haben eine Koalition die
ja gerade haben das gehört in Demut
vielleicht versucht weiter zu machen
also mit Verlierer Geschichten
konfrontiert ist aber ist das so einfach
aus diesem Ergebnis den Wähler Willen
abzulesen also klar für die CDU ist das
ist das ganz eindeutig aber ohne
Mehrheit schon halt auch schwierig ja
aber die mehrheitsregel ist ja das was
hier das Demokratieprinzip ausmacht
Demokratie ist organisierte Freiheit das
Instrument das zu organisieren ist die
mehrheitsregel insofern gibt es keine
gute Mehrheit keine falsche Mehrheit
keine richtige Mehrheit sondern wenn sie
formal richtig korrekt zustande kommt
kann auch jede Mehrheit am Ende
Koalition bilden und damit auch eine
Regierungsbildung es ist absolut legitim
so etwas zu machen man sucht sich aus
Minderheiten eine Mehrheit zusammen das
ist parlamentarische mit Steuerung und
es gab sehr viele historische Beispiele
bei dem nicht der Sieger am Ende den
jeweiligen Chef oder Chefin gestellt hat
und nun war die Union war die CDU ja in
Berlin im sehr erfolgreich auch mit dem
ganz klaren abgrenzungswahlkampf also
Herr Wegner hat das eigentlich so
gemacht das auch sauber macht sich da
auch gerade gegenüber den Grünen sehr
klar abgegrenzt Stichwort zwischen uns
liegen Welten und Koalitionen ganz
schwer macht es das jetzt schwieriger
Sondierungsgespräche zu führen ja
normalerweise gibt es koalitionssignale
vorher schon die gab es diesmal nicht es
ist aber auch ein koalitionsmarkt eben
entstanden nicht nur bei verschiedenen
Parteien sondern auch gegenüber uns WLAN
niemand legt sich mehr richtig fest und
das macht den koalitionsmarkt so
unberechenbar weil wir
lagerübergreifende Koalition haben aber
es gibt durchaus Möglichkeiten auch aus
der Unterschiedlichkeit die Stärken zu
groß zu machen also die die Differenz
ins Zentrum zurück nicht die
Schnittmenge und es gibt eben auch
Beispiele erste Anbahnung von
Koalitionspartnern von denen man es nie
erwartet hätte auch die große Koalition
erstmals als sie zustande kam war die
Überbrückung riesig aber er Wikinger hat
ja schon doch recht klar sich versucht
abzugrenzen also eigentlich an diesem
alle können mit allem und wir überlappen
uns mag den sie da gerade beschrieben
eben nicht teil ja aber das ist eine
Paartherapie werden die alle brauchen
aber die Auseinandersetzung kann man
natürlich schon so organisieren dass man
eine Koalition der Unterschiede stark
macht nicht nur in den Ressourcen dann
sagt euer Spielfeld wird bedient für
eure Klientel und unseres auch man kann
auch einen verzichtskonsens aushandeln
also ein Konsens über das was man nicht
vereinbart im Vorfeld es gibt also
Modelle die Unterschiedlichkeit
gegenüber dem WLAN stark zu lassen in
Koalition und nicht nach dem kleinsten
gemeinsamen Nenner zu suchen und die
Dynamik des Miteinanders zu stärken der
Politikwissenschaftler danke Ihnen die
Informationen und die Analyse für
Berlinwahl gibt es nachher im heute
schon mal Update dann noch ein Interview
mit dem früheren Regierenden
Bürgermeister Michael Müller von der SPD
wie schwierig das mit dem sich abgrenzen
werden kann wir hatten es ja gerade
erlebt die Union nun in spezieller Form
beim Umgang mit ihrem noch Mitglied
Hans-Georg Maaßen die CDU hat heute
beschlossen ihn aus der Partei zu werfen
an seiner Person soll gewissermaßen die
Brandmauer zu AFD definiert werden als
Politprofi kann es denn ehemaligen
Verfassungsschutzpräsident nicht
überraschen dass sein schwadronieren
über rassenlehren die eine Provokation
zu viel war
Massen könnte natürlich auch freiwillig
austreten oder zu AFD wechseln aber ob
er in einem Milieu Gleichgesinnter
genauso auffiele ist nicht gesagt an
sich womöglich über Jahre hinziehen des
Parteiausschlussverfahren hingegen
sichert langfristig Aufmerksamkeit und
Opferstatus mattes Feldhoff über das
Maßen die Lämmer der CDU
Friedrich Merz will heute entschieden
klingen kein Zweifel darf aufkommen dass
diese Entscheidung gut für die CDU ist
einstimmig hat der Bundesvorstand der
Partei heute Hans-Georg Maaßen die
Mitgliedsrechte entzogen der klare
Trennungsstrich ist mit dem heutigen Tag
gezogen und die Partei wird es uns in
ganz ganz großen Teilen danken und es
wird vor allen Dingen in der Bevölkerung
erkennbar werden wir sind konservativ
wir sind liberal wir sind christlich
sozial aber wir sind nicht rechtsradikal
Hans-Georg Maaßen und die CDU eine
Geschichte voller Schmerzen eine
Geschichte voller Radikalisierung und
vom Ende des Ertragbaren für die
Christdemokraten
unter drei Innenminister der Union war
Maaßen Chef des Verfassungsschutzes
schon früher umstritten für seine
Wortwahl als er in einer Rede von
linksradikalen Kräften in der SPD
spricht reicht es Horst Seehofer
versetzt den spitzenbaum in den
Ruhestand das ist jetzt vier Jahre her
nun ist das Fass übergelaufen wer Worte
wie rassenlehrer oder anti-deutscher
Rassismus benutze gehören nicht zur CDU
der ist immer einige Zentimeter
weitergegangen und verschiebt immer
weiter sein sein Spektrum sein
äußerungsspektrum nach Jahren nach
rechtsextremistischen Standpunkten es
ist eine Frage der Haltung für die Union
hier klar zu sein und deutlich zu machen
wir haben nach ganz links und nach ganz
rechts außen eine klare Linie der seine
Brandmauer überschritten worden von
Hans-Georg Maaßen Maßen wehrt sich gegen
seinen Parteiausschluss in einem Brief
bestreitet er alle Vorwürfe
die politische Zielrichtung der Schmutz
und Rufmordkampagne gegen mich besteht
offensichtlich darin eine Brandmauer in
der CDU gegenüber all denen zu errichten
die den Links grünen Kurs der
Parteiführung nicht mittragen wollen
links grüne Parteiführung ein Vorwurf
den Friedrich Merz offensichtlich gar
nicht komisch fand
erschwerend kommt hinzu dass Hans-Georg
Maaßen inzwischen auch Vorsitzender der
sogenannten werteunion ist einer
ultra-konservativen Gruppe außerhalb der
CDU auch von ihr grenzt sich die Union
ab wir sind Volkspartei und in dieser
Volkspartei werden Werte gelebt dafür
braucht es keine Gruppierungen außerhalb
der normalen Ordnung unserer Partei
jetzt wird vor dem Partei Gericht in
Thüringen verhandelt dort wo Maßen
Mitglied der CDU ist ein Verfahren das
sehr lange dauern kann
und dann blicken wir jetzt auf die
Katastrophengebiete in der Türkei und
Syrien tausende liegen weiter unter den
Trümmern aber die Hoffnung schwindet
jetzt noch lebende ausgraben zu können
in diesem schrecklichen Wettlauf gegen
die Zeit rannten die Retter im Norden
Syriens von Anfang an mit bloßen Füßen
und leeren Händen kaum Einsatzkräfte
kaum Gerät und keine Hilfe von außen
nichts und niemand kam bisher in diese
Gebiete hinein die letzten die vom
Regime in Damaskus noch nicht
zurückerobert wurden
internationale Hilfskonvois kennen oder
durch wenn sich die Vereinten Nationen
über die interessenersatz und seiner
Schutz macht Russland hinwegsetzen
würden das ist in einem Kriegsgebiet
leichter gesagt als getan und so sieht
die Welt beschämt ratlos zu bei dieser
Katastrophe in der Katastrophe olinea
wo blieb eure Hilfe eure bergungsstrupps
Eure Ärzte fragen Sie die Welt fragen
Sie die Vereinten Nationen eine
Protestaktion in Nordwest Syrien dort wo
Millionen leben die vor dem Regime ihres
machthabes viele Male geflohen waren
sind nun tausende tot
dort wo er herrscht ist Hilfe eher
schnell angekommen das Erdbeben hat
Baschar alle asset fast so etwas wie
neue Legitimität verschafft immer mehr
Länder bauen ihre Beziehungen mit ihm
aus liefern ihm Lebensmittel schicken
Experten und suchts
wo sie leben hatten Assad und sein
Verbündeter Russland vor dem Beben
regelmäßig Raketen geschickt und
Zerstörung gebracht ihr Überleben wird
hier entschieden im UN-Sicherheitsrat
Syriens Verbündete Russland konnte hier
die Hilfe für Nordwest Syrien über Jahre
immer weiter reduzieren sogar
Erdbebenhilfe haben sie jetzt
erfolgreich verhindert all das geführt
dazu dass es eine Situation ergibt dass
das Regime das bombardiert hat seine
eigene Bevölkerung am meisten humanitäre
Hilfe in seinen Territorium geliefert
bekommen dort wo die Raketen landen wo
die Zerstörung geschieht am wenigsten
angekommen ist das ist absurd und das
ist gegen die Neutralität Prinzipien und
die
unparteilichkeitsprinzipien die
humanitäre Hilfe eigentlich folgen muss
während Menschen unter den Trümmern
sterben ist der UN-Generalsekretär zum
Warten verdammt erwartet und wartet auf
den UN-Sicherheitsrat um weitere
Grenzübergänge zu öffnen solche Hilfe
Hengst politisch und nicht neutral
kritisieren Experten es gehe nicht um
die Not der Menschen sondern nur noch um
die absolute Souveränität eines
Diktators
es gibt eine starke Schule des
progressiven modernen Völkerrechts das
sagt wir haben die Möglichkeit zu
liefern auch von der UN aus ohne den
Sicherheitsrat zu fragen also eine
staatliche Souveränität die nicht
absolut ist wo ein Herrscher nicht
absolut machen kann mit seiner
Bevölkerung was er will London hier
haben internationale Strafrechtler und
namhafte Monaten die un-praxis der Hilfe
für nordwest-
humanitäre Völkerrecht sagen sie
der UN-Sicherheitsrat ist ein
politisches Gremium und diente einem
politischen Zweck es kann nicht
langfristig darüber bestimmen ob
Millionen von Menschen Hilfe bekommen
oder nicht in den nächsten Monaten
werden wir diese harten Fragen angehen
müssen
die UN haben bislang keine Stellung
genommen zu den Vorwürfen aber um nicht
noch mehr Menschen leben zu verlieren
sagen ihre Kritiker müsse die
Weltgemeinschaft die Politik beiseite
lassen
immerhin von den Vereinten Nationen New
York kam jetzt am Abend noch die Meldung
das Syriens Assad immerhin zugestimmt
hat zwei weitere Grenzpunkte zur Türkei
zu öffnen für drei Monate um Hilfe in
den Nordwesten Syriens zuzulassen
hoffentlich kommt das dann auch so wenn
sie spenden wollen das ist
Aktionsbündnis Katastrophenhilfe hat
folgendes Konto die
e65-100 400 600-100 400 600 Stichwort
ZDF Erdbeben Türkei Syrien
informationen auch unter
spenden.zdf.de oder im ZDF Text auf
Seite 890
mit Nachrichten geht es weiter bei dir
Heinz und da zunächst mit dem Blick auf
die Ukraine ja damit befassen sich
erneut auch den
autoverteidigungsminister Morgen bei
einer Sitzung im Hauptquartier in
Brüssel Generalsekretär Stoltenberg
sagte heute unter anderem weitere
Munition Treibstoff und Ersatzteile
müssten die Ukraine erreichen bevor
Russland wieder die Initiative auf dem
Schlachtfeld ergreifen können
inzwischen hat die Bundeswehr begonnen
ukrainische Soldaten am Kampfpanzer
Leopard 2 auszubilden das Training
findet hauptsächlich im
niedersächsischen Munster Stadt
in Jerusalem haben Zehntausende gegen
die tiefgreifende Justizreform der
rechtsreligiösen Regierung demonstriert
derweil billigte der Justizausschuss in
der Knesset einen Teil der Reform
deswegen ist dort zu tumultartigen
Szenen kam
Gegner der Reform hatten sich vor dem
Parlamentsgebäude versammelt der
Reformpläne sehen vor dass Urteile des
höchsten Gerichts vom Parlament
aufgehoben werden könnten und die
Politik größeren Einfluss auf die
Ernennung von Richterinnen und Richtern
erhält
sechs Monate nach einem tödlichen
Angriff auf einen 25-Jährigen Transmann
beim Christopher Street Day in Münster
hat heute der Prozess begonnen vor dem
Landgericht muss ich ein 20-jähriger
wegen Körperverletzung mit Todesfolge
verantworten der Angeklagte hat die
Vorwürfe eingeräumt er soll mehrere
Personen homophob beleidigt und einen
Transmann der dazwischen ging geschlagen
haben
in Dresden wurde am Abend an die
Zerstörung der Stadt 1945 und die Opfer
des Nationalsozialismus erinnert vor 78
Jahren wurde Dresden durch
Bombenangriffe der Alliierten weitgehend
zerstört bis zu 25.000 Menschen starben
unter dem Motto Frieden gemeinsam
gestalten formierte sich eine
Menschenkette durch die Innenstadt viele
gedachten mit Kerzen der Opfer von Krieg
und Nationalsozialismus zudem gab es
mehrere Mahnwachen und einen
ökumenischen friedensgottesdienst
als der chinesische riesenballon über
dem nordamerikanischen Himmel auftauchte
gab das vielen noch Anlass für
Witzeleien auch als noch ein weiteres
unbekanntes Flugobjekt auftauchte allein
schon der Begriff fährt ja dazu ein
inzwischen sind allerdings noch zwei
weitere UFOs abgeschossen worden im
Luftraum über den USA und Kanada und so
langsam findet das kaum noch jemand
lustig was steckt dahinter
spionierung tun alle aber warum so
offensichtlich war das hier ein
Testballon oder vielen solche Objekte
früher nur nicht so auf beziehungsweise
wurden geflissentlich ignoriert viele
Fragen bislang noch wenig offizielle
Antworten Claudia Bates berichtet aus
den USA
die Presse wartet auf Antworten der
Druck auf den Präsidenten sich zu
erklären steigt aber noch schickt er die
Sprecher vor die Kameras noch sucht die
US-Regierung offenbar nach Erklärungen
eine militärische Bedrohung habe zu
keinem Zeitpunkt bestanden
wir hatten keine Anzeichen dass die
letzten drei Objekte der Spionage
dienten aber wir konnten es auch nicht
ausschließen insofern gehen wir auf
Nummer sicher und schützen unsere
nationalen Sicherheitsinteressen deshalb
hat der Präsident mit der Empfehlung
seiner militärischen Führung sie
abschießen lassen
vier Flugobjekte wurden inzwischen von
Kampfflugzeugen über Nordamerika
abgeschossen zunächst der erste große
Ballon nach us-erkenntnissen ein
chinesischer spionageballon am 4 februar
vor der Küste von South Carolina
vergangenen Freitag dann vor der Küste
Alaskas bei Bruder Bay ein silbergraues
Objekt der Größe eines Kleinwagens am
Samstag ein zylindrischer Körper über
dem kanadischen Yukon auch bei diesen
soll es sich um Balance gehandelt haben
und gestern über dem heron-see 6000 m
Flughöhe eine Gefahr für die zivile
Luftfahrt der Blick richtet sich nach
China dessen Spionageaktivitäten man
genauer unter die Lupe genommen habe
vieles von dem was wir in Erfahrung
bringen ist natürlich sensibel aber wir
konnten ermitteln dass China ein
Spionageprogramm mit hoch fliegenden
Ballons unterhält das in Verbindung
steht mit der Volksbefreiungsarmee
China bestreitet weiterhin dass der
erste große Ballon der Spionage diente
während seine Trümmer noch geborgen
werden eskaliert der Konflikt der Worte
den China seinerseits erhebt nun schwere
Vorwürfe gegen die USA
das illegale Eindringen in den Luftraum
anderer Länder durch us-ballons ist
alltäglich allein seit letztem Jahr sind
Balance der USA mehr als 10 mal in den
chinesischen Luftraum eingedrungen ohne
die Genehmigung der chinesischen
Behörden
die US-Regierung bezeichnet das als
absolut falsch ein Gespräch mit dem
US-Verteidigungsminister hat China
abgelehnt die USA haben die Beobachtung
ihres Luftraums umgestellt so dass auch
kleinere langsamere Objekte überhaupt
wahrgenommen werden wohl auch deshalb
erscheinen jetzt mehr davon auf dem
Radar erst wenn ihre Trümmer geborgen
und analysiert sind wird wohl klar was
am Himmel über Nordamerika gerade
passiert es gebe keinen Hinweis auf
Außerirdische betont das Weiße Haus
dass diese mutmaßlichen
spionageinstrumente in diesen Zeiten
eine andere Aufmerksamkeit bekommen und
bedrohliche empfunden werden liegt auf
der Hand die Balance schweben über einer
stürmischen Weltlage mit dem russischen
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine und den im
Zuge dessen noch angespannteren
Beziehungen zu China
zu den vielen Nebenwirkungen dieser
gewaltigen zeitenwände gehört dass sich
das westliche Bündnis einmal mehr
erweitert in eine Richtung die vor einem
Jahr noch undenkbar gewesen wäre nämlich
das Schweden und Finnland ihre
militärpolitische Neutralität aufgeben
und der nato-beiträgen wollen
Außenministerin Werbung war heute zu
besuchen Finnland andreas war dabei
unter dem Lake yoola-platz in Helsinki
liegt ein offenes Geheimnis es ist für
alle Finnen offen und zwar rund um die
Uhr und man sieht ihm seine riesigen
Ausmaße weder von außen an noch von den
zehn Stockwerken aus die man
hinabklettern muss bis man da ist an
diesem Abend steht die deutsche
Außenministerin unter dem lakiola-platz
und lässt sich die Toiletten für den
Ernstfall zeigen die Betten für den
Ernstfall und die Hockey Tore für den
Normalfall denn das ist das Geheimnis
tief unter Helsinki dass die 400 Bunker
die die Bevölkerung im Kriegsfall vor
dem Tod retten sollen im Frieden voller
Leben und lachen sind Werbung ist dafür
ist den Finnen in Deutschland
nachzumachen und erstmals seit Jahren
wieder Bunker zu bauen die aber nicht
nur Bunker sind
deswegen solche Anlagen so zu bauen dass
sie in friedlichen Zeiten die
hoffentlich für immer sein werden
genutzt werden können aber eine Vorsorge
zu treffen weil Vorsorge ist gerade in
diesen Zeiten der beste Schutz Finnland
hat einen besonderen Blick auf diese
Zeiten das 1939 sowjetische Panzer
versuchten die finnische Republik zu
erobern ist
nationaltrauma und prägt Helsinki's
Außenpolitik bis heute Russlands
Überfall auf die Ukraine lässt die
Regierung ihre jahrzehntelange
Bündnisfreiheit beenden Finnland strebt
nicht nur in die NATO sondern sendet
auch Hilfsgüter und Waffen in die
Ukraine bärburg kommt um ihren Kollegen
zu bitten gemeinsam mit Deutschland
Leopard zwei Panzer zu liefern Finland
verfügt über etwa 200 aber ist zögert
weil es die längste europäische Grenze
zu Russland hat die finnische Regierung
hat noch keine endgültige Entscheidung
getroffen
den sogenannten Winterkrieg gegen die
Sowjetunion hat Finnland 1940 gewonnen
aber dieses ungute Gefühl zwischen
Vorsicht und Sorge nie verloren
natürlich sind die Leute besorgt wir
sind so nah an Russland wir haben diese
lange spezielle Geschichte mit Ihnen und
wir bauen seit Ewigkeiten diese Bunker
und ja wir merken dass die Leute wieder
Angst bekommen
für alle 900.000 Einwohner des Großraums
helsinki ist Platz unter der Hauptstadt
Helsinki's Geheimnis ist offen und jeder
der es kennt hofft dass es nie schließen
muss
die wirtschaftlichen Folgen des
russischen Krieges scheinen für Europa
bisher nicht so schlimm wie befürchtet
und mit diesen Jahr durchaus positiven
Nachricht geht es jetzt bei dir weiter
Heinz nach der neuen Prognose der
EU-Kommission entwickelt sich die
Wirtschaft stabiler als erwartet und
zwar für Europa insgesamt und auch für
Deutschland im Vergleich zu der
Einschätzung im Herbst jetzt also ein
optimistischerer Blick auf die
Wirtschaft bei der Halle was sind die
Gründe da gibt es eine ganze Reihe eine
entscheidender Gas kostet nicht mehr
ganz so viel der Preis ist sogar auf den
niedrigsten Stand seit fast eineinhalb
Jahren gerutscht das liegt am milden
Winter es wurde also weniger Gas
verbraucht und auch daran dass sich die
Europäer neue Bezugsquellen außerhalb
Russlands gesucht haben also die
Gasspeicher sind gut gefüllt und damit
wird unwahrscheinlicher das
energierationiert werden muss außerdem
ist die Arbeitslosigkeit in der Eurozone
so niedrig wie lange nicht und all das
zusammengenommen lässt die Experten in
Brüssel wieder etwas positiver für die
Zukunft schauen für die Eurozone rechnen
Sie dieses Jahr mit einem Wachstum von
0,9 Prozent auch für Deutschland sieht
es wieder etwas besser aus
+0,2% mit einer Belebung wird erst in
der zweiten Jahreshälfte gerechnet
Deutschland hat aufgrund seiner
energiehungrigen Industrie besonders
unter den hohen Gas- und Strompreisen
gelitten insgesamt aber ist Europa
besser durch die Krise gekommen als
erwartet Entwarnung will die
EU-Kommission aber noch nicht geben ein
Risikofaktor ist nach wie vor die
Inflation vor allem wenn die Löhne über
längere Zeit überdurchschnittlich
steigen die bessere Prognose aus Brüssel
beflügelt auch den DAX der kann heute
wieder zulegen um mehr als ein halbes
Prozent und wenn der DAX so weitermacht
dann hat er bald die gesamten Verluste
vom vergangenen Jahr wieder weggemacht
vielen Dank
und zum Schluss noch ein Rückblick auf
die vergangene Nacht und den superbau
gewonnen haben die Kansas City Chiefs
Patrick mahomes im Konfetti
Freudentaumel zum zweiten Mal in vier
Jahren gewinnt der Star quarter back den
Super Bowl mit seinen Kansas City Chiefs
das Spiel ein Kopf an Kopf rennen bis
kurz vor Schluss starke Aktionen auch
von Philadelphia squarterback Jane hurts
beim Spielstand von 35 zu 35 dann der
große Moment von Kika Harrison sein
field Gold bringt den Schiffs die
entscheidenden drei Punkte für den Sieg
knapp 70.000 Fans kamen ins Stadion um
einen Abend ganz im Sinne des Sports zu
feiern
wir die Nationalhymne singen spüren wir
dass wir immer noch ein Land sind und so
sollte es doch sein die Halbzeit wurde
zum großen Rihanna Comeback nach rund
sechs Jahren Auszeit von der Musik nach
der Show ließ sie noch die Überraschung
verkünden dass sie mit ihrem zweiten
Kind schwanger ist am Ende liegen sich
auch die beiden Kerl ziebrüder die
gegeneinander antraten in den Armen so
bleibt der Superbowl in Erinnerung als
Abend der großen Geschichten an dem es
Amerika trotz aller gesellschaftlichen
Differenzen schaffte für einen Moment
zusammen zurück
das war es von uns hier geht es jetzt
weiter mit dem montagskino heute mit
einem norwegischen Thriller und um 23
Uhr gibt es dann unsere heute schnell
Update mit Gundula Gause
[Musik]
guten Abend über Deutschland thront ein
hoch das bedeutet für viele dichten
hochnehmen und recht tiefe Temperaturen
für andere dagegen strahlenden
Sonnenschein und so stiegen die
Temperaturen heute in Köln bis 16 Grad
im dauergrauer der Donau blieb es bei 1
Grad deutlich kälter heute Nacht sinken
die Temperaturen auf drei Grad in
Ostfriesland am Niederrhein und bis
minus fünf Grad an den Alpen in
Süddeutschland könnten sie sich da also
auf reisglätte Einstellen der Nebel und
Dunst können am gefrorenen Boden
festfrieren die hochnebeldecke hält sich
Zähne im Norden und im Nordosten und
auch morgen haben wir es noch mit der zu
tun die meisten von uns dürfen sich aber
nach Nebel und Dunst auch viel
Sonnenschein einstellen und je nachdem
ob es bei ihnen grau bleibt liegen die
Höchsttemperaturen morgen um die 5 Grad
mit Sonnenschein geht's dann in den
deutlich zweistelligen Bereich
vielleicht wieder auf 15 16 Grad noch
wärmer ist es in kontinental Europa
eigentlich nur
wütende iberischen Halbinsel mit 20 Grad
dieses hoch allerdings das uns diese
hohen Temperaturen bringt das
verabschiedet sich in den nächsten Tagen
weiter nach Süden und dann kommen uns
die Tiefs von Norden näher das bedeutet
für den Freitag dass es ein Sturmtief
geben wird ist jedenfalls derzeit die
Meinung aller Modelle der Mittwoch
bringt noch mal schönes Wetter am
Donnerstag kommt schon der Regen heran
und der Freitag wird ein sehr
durchwachsen und wahrscheinlich
stürmisch guten Abend